okay so this year we had 6915 script
applications for this fellowship how do
we arrive at choosing the five finalists
well you know that phone and mochi that
looks like an arrow or dart that's
sticking into a target that's not how we
do it I will give you a little peek into
the process the organizational heavy
lifting of the whole program gets done
by two academy staff members that I have
to thank tonight Greg Beal and Joan why
Greg and Joan wrangle a small army of
paid readers who do the first round of
reading of all those nearly 7,000
scripts that come in every year the
readers follow specific evaluation
guidelines that the nickel committee has
put together for them and in fact all
the readers who read all the way through
at every stage are following these same
guidelines they the nickel committee is
like as a base requirement you have to
love writers love screenwriting and
value it and have some understanding of
what goes into making a good script and
I do give a lot of thought to balancing
our committee by gender arrays
background we balance it by professional
backgrounds as well the different
branches of the Academy so there's like
a little science to putting together the
18 or so people they get to sit in that
room so in the we read these scripts
blind to we don't know anything about
where the script came from we see a
title lumen there's a number under it
and then that's all we get so we feel
like we give it the fairest read we
possibly can in that that huge tranche
of 7,000 scripts actually gets read
twice and the highest scoring of those
scripts this year was over 12,000 1,200
scripts came in that got to be read a
third time which allowed us to then
winnow the field down to
quarter-finalists roughly the top 5% of
the 7,000 go on to be quarter-finalists
those quarter-final scripts get read
three more times
we then take the best of five of the six
scores to identify the semi-finalists so
this year was 148 of those those got red
four times each this time by academy
members who are again drawn from across
all the branches of the 200 members who
judged the semi-final scripts this year
53 were Academy Award winners or
nominees so then we use the best of
eight of 10 scores to an hour the field
to our finalists and that group can
range anywhere from 10 to 15 scripts
will end up being the final scripts and
those scripts are the ones that the
nickel committee itself reads and we
usually read them twice over each then
we're ready to deliberate so upstairs is
a room on the seventh floor that has a
big swooping oval doughnut of a table
that looks like it came from the Empire
Strikes Back and we sit there when we
discuss the plan with scripts for hours
because I chair the meeting I get to
play Darth Vader it gets tense we differ
we agree and then we differ we get
swayed by an impassioned rant you know
from one of us and sometimes we change
our votes you know and it sometimes you
change it back we have snacks it's fun
and it's it's fun not just because of
the ranting but because of you because
the writing in these line list scripts
is always amazing that is actually what
makes it so tense because we don't have
the capacity to support more than five
fellows a year so that becomes our
creative boundary and because we have a
creative boundary those of you who write
know that's when it gets exciting so
believe me up there at that weird table
there is some point in that meeting in
which we really go back and forth about
scripts number five and number six
because we have to get it down to five
but somehow out of this long and
passionate meeting we five nickel
fellows emerge and then I have to say
that something else happens in that room
which is that all of us who are doing
this judging become really inspired by
the process
by the things that were said in the room
and above all by the work that we've
read and discussed we become inspired by
the voices that we are here to honor
tonight and we come away reminded of our
own desire to do our best work in our
most personal work because what
invariably rises to the top of those
seven thousand scripts our writers who
are capable of doing what friends Kafka
described in a letter to a friend when
he was still a rather young ripe writer
Kafka was talking about books but if you
were writing now I think it's likely he
would be saying this about the movies I
think we ought to read only the kind of
books that wound or stab us if it
doesn't wake us up with a blow to the
head what are we reading for we need
books that affect us like a disaster
that grieve us deeply like the death of
someone we loved more than ourselves
like being banished into forests far
from everyone like a suicide a book must
be the acts for the frozen sea inside us
so in that room we end up choosing
writers who give us access to the great
ocean of shared human experience
contained in all of us tonight the
nickel fellowship honors and encourages
the future work of these nickel fellows
for 2016 Michelle Atkins Lloyd Harvey
and Spencer Harvey Geeta Malik Elizabeth
owe you bday and Justin Piasecki
and here tonight to give you a glimpse
of their current work is a longtime
nickel supporter writer-director Rodrigo
Garcia
come over here cuz I'm an embarrassing
that was that not supposed to come okay
not too early cuz now you have to stand
here while I talk about you I wrote in
part he's not getting away okay Regina
has made a really daunting list of
wonderful movies they're always really
innovative movies too he made one movie
call nine lives which was nine separate
lives nine camera moves no cuts that is
a great movie he made mother and child
you do the Aastra nominated Albert Nobbs
things you can tell just by looking at
her and plus the long-running TV show in
treatment and he recently wrote and
directed a film last days in the desert
that I think about just about every day
it stars Ewan McGregor it's a really
haunting film it had a limited arthouse
releases this year which means not
enough people saw this incredible movie
but it's streaming now on Netflix and
iTunes and you really have to see it
last days in the desert it is a prime
example of an experienced artist at work
so that was embarrassing